chris hogan here i've spent so much time
on the road and talked with a lot of
people and the millionaire success
stories that are run into might surprise
you you're gonna get a glimpse into the
life of a self-made millionaire who
these folks are hard at work you don't
want to miss it people this is
millionaire I'm Jim Powell I live
outside of Cincinnati an area called
Anderson Township I am yes I spent 20
years in the Air Force most of that time
flying b-52s I then went to Camaro and I
was able to get a job at them and I flew
them for 14 years then up to a corporate
jet for another three years so I spent
most of the time flying errands that's
what I've done for the last thirty 17
years plus another Tim when I haven't
done anything I've been retired you know
you hear about the guys who fly the big
airplanes and make 200 thousand a year
and they say that was never my case when
I flew for Carnera I think the most I
ever made toward the end of my career I
still made about ninety thousand a year
but the rest of the time I was making
about 40,000 45,000 that sort of thing
plus my military charlie so I think the
attitude that I went at in terms of
saving had more to do with it than
anything else
I was just lucky that I got a chance to
do what I wanted to do which is why
airplanes
I found some time not too long ago to
put a book together I decided to call it
of Dreams and coveralls in that book
what I primarily talk about is picking
yourself up when you fall down there's a
chapter in there that talks about going
from a point where I'm owing several
different people money to won't work and
finally oh no one and have money set
aside what happened I had somebody who
called me and when he called me he
talked very harsh because over the money
which really angered me but the more I
thought of it the more I realized I was
at fault because I put myself in that
particular sation position what happened
was I said okay this isn't everyone
happened again
I'm never gonna be in position where I
owe another man a dollar bill I'm just
not gonna do that so I started trying to
pay off my bills I paid out the first
bill which was about $75 not more than
making about $180 a month at the time so
that was quite a bit but when I got that
bill paid off I took the money from that
and I added that to the next bill and
then the next and the next next so I got
them all paid off
when Ruth and I got married she had
about $2,500 and bills so they became
our bills it weren't just her bills
there were our bills so I said we buy
nothing until we get the bills paid off
that you have because if you're trying
to save money the best way to save money
is we you know anybody we worked on it
we paid off one and then the next and
the next and the next
we were debt-free within two and a half
years after getting married and we've
been that way all of their lives okay we
went into that I went into the air
because I should say and at that time I
started saving $100 a month I made five
hundred I saved hundred when I got
promoted from second lieutenant to first
lieutenant I saved another hundred I had
started saving about $1,100 a month by
time I left the military and I continued
doing that I had bought a couple new
house and every time I get extra money
from those I'll put that money into
Mutual's and then I started putting
money away for the kids education we
found ourselves saving and investing and
continue to do it over a period of time
it just kind of forgetting about it just
letting it take care of itself
by the time they got ready to go to
college at somewhere between fifty and
sixty thousand dollars for each one of
them so that they wouldn't have to worry
about it and I would have to worry about
it I had another count for my wife and
me and there's about a hundred and fifty
thousand and also we met with our
financial planner and he says to me you
guys have done very well for what you
make I wasn't making a lot of time I had
a military timer which is about $30,000
retiring at that time I was working for
Comair and I think I was making about
forty five thousand with them my wife
was a teacher making about fifty
thousand he says high of a clap that
makes over a million dollars here you
make some million about 30,000 40,000 a
year something like that and you two
guys are better off than he is
you take sack lunches to work you drive
cars on three four five six years of age
and all that sort of thing
you save periodically you
stay out of dip one day we met with him
he said let me show you something and he
did some figures and all he said here's
your net worth and it was in his excess
of a million dollars and I didn't even
know it at the time I was just trying to
make sure that we were going to be okay
just in case financially
I know of several individuals who are
black who are millionaires and they
don't make a lot of money did make on it
I know of an individual where a husband
ever say anything but she saved about
ten thousand dollars a year and she did
secretarial work so you make a lot of
money and about 80 84 85 years is worth
a couple of million dollars just from
doing that long one individual has
worked two or three jobs he's reaching
millionaire status I can think of right
offhand about 7-8 people grab the
african-american who are millionaires
okay it's available to everybody black
or white I think sometimes though if you
don't recognize what's possible then you
may perceive that that's a problem when
it really isn't my opinion I think it's
the habit that you employ that makes all
the difference in the world whether or
not you get to be a millionaire or not I
think the first thing I tell someone who
wants to do this phase though first the
second thing I would say is get out of
debt and stay out of it
and if you're married I think it's
important that you vote from the same
sheet if you're not on the same sheet of
music you got a situation worth one mule
is pulling one direction other noodles
pull another direction the wagon doesn't
go anywhere okay whether you're trying
to get to $500,000 if you're trying to
get to 750 thousand or a meal whatever
they haven't speak if you're trying to
reach this goal financially and you're
concentrating on all the obstacles in
between and what-have-you then you're
wasting the energy on them that you
could be using to get to that goal and
that's what you need to do that's where
your focus needs to be if you're doing
the right things not only when you get
there but you'll get beyond that point
because of something called compounding
interest Einstein was at some time
before he passed what was the most
powerful force in the universe and you
talk about gravity anything like that
mainly spotted compound Incas and it
works for everybody you don't have to
make a whole lot of money you need to
consistently save in the one and then in
addition to that you need to get out of
debt and stat it and it does know if
you're black or white or green or purple
or chartreuse okay you need to do those
things
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]